marie laure était lent courtoise elle
avait participé l'année dernière au
projet de gans mené par olivier dubois
au prisme comblé par cette expérience
artistique marie laure s'est inscrite au
nouvel atelier du chorégraphe jean
claude gallotta
je trouve que c'est une occasion
extraordinaire de danser avec des gens
qu'on connaît pas forcément de tout
niveau qu'on soit simple danseurs où il
ya un peu plus expérimentés et ce lien
qui se crée entre nous et le plaisir de
danser est une expérience à partager une
expérience à partager entre plusieurs
générations
c'est le défi de jean claude gallotta
réunir et faire danser des amateurs de
tous âges pour la nuit blanche de saint
quentin en yvelines pour les enfants 4
50 enfants
après il donne la place à 50 adultes qui
refont un peu des gestes qu'on a un peu
vu avec eux et puis ensuite tous les
gens se déplacent ils vont sur
l'esplanade et là il voit la troisième
génération en fait des personnes âgées
qui refonde d'autres gestes et quand ces
personnes âgées ont terminé en fait
toutes les générations se retrouvent sur
l'esplanade et fonde une danse où il ya
150 danseurs en fait je trouvais ça
magnifique cette idée que tout le monde
peut être danseur et que tout le monde
peut danser de la maternelle jusqu'à la
tombe
le groupe des seniors répète depuis le
mois de juin avec yannick assistant de
jean claude gallotta
c'est une expérience assez touchante je
trouve de voir le mouvement traverser
les corps en fait qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de bouger et
puis voilà voir toutes les étapes du
travail aussi bien le début les corps
qui sont complètement fermés au
mouvement et qui est au bout de trois
semaines de travail soient complètement
25 personnes de 50 à 82 ans composent le
groupe numéro trois un groupe très
assidus et motivés
aujourd'hui justement on travaille sur
la précision et on se rend compte qu'on
a interprété chacun des gestes à notre
façon avec notre style
il ya des fois on me dit que c'est bien
il ya des fois au contraire c'est pas
bien du tout il faut être très strictes
un cours de danse qui réserve bien des
surprises un temps une de nous et qui
n'était de loin pas la plus jeune qui a
fait le grand écart devant nos yeux
ébahis
prochaine étape la rencontre avec les
autres groupes pour la suite des
répétitions avant le spectacle final
interprété au prisme à elancourt lors de
la nuit blanche de saint quentin en
yvelines
le saint vith 6 octobre
[Applaudissements]